someone said okay well why did genghis
khan put together the greatest
contiguous land empire seen in the
middle ages and like the answer isn't
just because he was hard
but i went through like a whole like
well the structure of mongol tribal
society in the late 12th century was
such and such and there are some climate
factors probably at play and you know
the relative
organization of genghis khan's
meritocratic uh reorganized mongol army
is versus the decadent imperial
societies
i didn't mention the guy who must have
just been like double heart
don jones welcome to the show
thank you very much thanks for having me
do you ever think about how much time
people that are really really stoned
have spent watching you walk around
great british castles
i haven't like broken it down into um
i like segmented it according to
intoxicants
i mean i'm aware dimly
that there's
like a weird number of people
not just in the uk where i live but
worldwide who've watched
secrets of great british castles
um i hadn't
given much thought to
like to as a stoner thing
are you gonna tell me otherwise i think
you'd be surprised i have a burgeoning
group of students that work for me many
of whom i know their go-to program if
they're
blazed out of their mind
is to get secrets of great british
castles on
wow
that's
that's pretty weird that does weird me
outside i mean it doesn't i'm not not in
a bad way
but um
that would that would definitely ruin my
buzz i think it's been a long time
it's been a long time uh so i don't
i'm sort of out of touch with my um
with my blaze mind but i well of course
it would naturally freak me out
yeah well i think he'd be surprised i
can't give you i can't give you a um
like an objective view on this soft
sultry tones no fast movements
no
there's a lot of those good camera work
yep good color paletting nice nice
presets nice lutz on it i reckon
yeah i reckon lean into it for the next
one find the most psychedelic castle
that you can
i'm not your optimism we'll ever get
another series of that show
it's been a long time now
you know i made that show back in
20 when we did the first series i think
that was like
2013 14 15 that kind of time we did that
and and that's now getting to be a while
ago like i think i might have been in my
now i can't have been in my 20s when i
started it but i was only just out of
them yeah and now i'm 40.
sure
yeah i like and i sort of do
i think if my
if if and when because let's be honest
it's always a when in tv
my my career just like
hits the wall of the tunnel and crumples
uh and all that's left is my back
catalogue
um
it'll be cut there'll be a point at
which people stop recognizing me in the
street and going oh my god oh my god
you're the castle guy
and start being like
that old dude there
looks like long gray hair at the side
but none at the top shambling around
smelling of his own urine that looks
like an old version of the castle
he really looked after himself he was so
youthful and sprightly and look at him
now clean-shaven yeah serious at the
right moment
is he fighting a pigeon over there is
that his pigeon is that somebody else's
yeah
we should help that guy no no he
probably smells like that's
that's my future but if i can see that
as your your trajectory man i think and
then the stoners will still love you
because for them no time has elapsed at
all well that but then the hope in this
in this narrative is then it's like
the redemption is the very very late
phase kind of
hipster revival yeah and i clean up a
bit and get a haircut gotta find that
same leather jacket again
yes
it's like squeezing into that actually
not squeezing into it because i'm so
thin and scrawny from malnutrition
and it's just hanging loose over me
like a
guy forks
dummy or a scarecrow
new book is about the middle ages hey
hey hey guys that's funny it's good at
the moment check it out we haven't lost
it yet
uh yet new book middle ages what's so
good about the middle ages
why is it so special
well it's special to me
uh i've you know i spent my whole career
to date
more or less in the middle ages i mean i
i
when i was a student i was studying
medieval legal history
and then i've written 10 books eight of
them have been about the middle ages
including this one powers and thrones so
um
i you know so this is a personal reason
i've just spent a lot of time i like i
think
i think it's a it's a nice like if
you're sort of choosing from the menu of
historical periods to
delve into it's got a nice
sort of combination of the
vaguely familiar and totally weird if
that makes any sense so there's i think
there's um
there's times in history where you can
or periods in history where it just
feels a little like
journalism you know if we talk about the
wars of this of the 20th century you
know some of us and my grandparents were
all to some degree or other involved in
the second world war
uh
so like that doesn't feel
that feels normal that feels like oh
yeah that's just us with
flat caps on or whatever
tin helmet
uh you go but you go back like way back
to
i'd say the bronze age if you read
though that mary renault book
the king is dead you heard that no
it's a great
merino was a great um
historical fiction author a fantastic
novelist and she wrote a book called the
king is dead which is about uh theses in
the minotaur and it's for me the most or
sort of
not authentic we don't know but most
believable
rendition of what bronze age
athens and crete were like and what the
minotaur could or could not have been um
and it's
it sets up that world as almost
completely alien it's like you've just
gone to a different planet there's
almost nothing that connects us with
those primates that were also homo
sapiens
now the middle ages sits between those
two things the totally alien and the
totally familiar and
one turn you can be
um
be touched
deeply and immediately by what seems to
be a sort of human constant between us
and them and and then you turn a corner
and it's like wow
that's so crazy you guys thought what so
um
that's why i like it that's what and
it's also a repository of amazing
stories
i've spent a lot of time writing british
history and
plantagenet dynastic history and of
course the
you know from henry's second element of
aquatain through to
uh you know the wars edward the first
wars for britain or the 100 years war or
wars the roses whatever whatever that's
all those are all great stories that are
part of a national story no our national
history the canon of our national
history um quite old-fashioned but still
exciting um but you know you throw the
lens open to a book like powers and
thrones which you know i've tried to go
as broad as possible and you've just got
like the greatest hits some of the
greatest hits of history reside in this
particular period it's like if you were
going to do a history of popular music
you'd be spending on like a lot a lot of
time between the 50s and the 70s right
and the middle age is a bit like that
like a lot of the good tunes are in the
middle ages
and it's there's a lot of analogies
there it's book ended between two
roman sackings as well that was quite
cool to find out that the middle ages is
parentheses by
rome getting [ __ ] twice
well the commission there was a very
concise commission
20
19 i think
i think it was 2019.
i went to clifton to a literary festival
and my publisher anthony treat him to
whom this book is dedicated was there
and anthony is
a great man and a great publisher and a
dear friend of mine
anybody gets the point
and uh he said
history in the middle ages i mean that
was how the conversation started hi
anthony how are you i'm good history of
the middle ages
second row
just like a row
wonder
i said yeah yeah for sure okay good and
then they drop the contracts like that
that's how our commissioning process has
worked in in the past uh so the only
like information i had to go on
to begin with was well here here are
some bookends you used to do the bid in
the middle but that's why he's a great
publisher because he sees things in
these enormous broad strokes and the
the pillars of the story and then you
you know go away and build it his
visionary and i don't use that term
lightly it's easy it's for all that he
might be visionary
giving someone a thousand years of
history to try and put into a book when
you don't have to go and do the research
yourself
that is
it's laying out the battle plans but not
having to uh
sort of step foot in the mud quite so
much
yeah it's a great general
[Laughter]
yeah directing around
all right so look i i love that i love
that that's the challenge i don't like i
don't take well to micromanagement you
give me
a task i will perform it and i will
usually although not always but usually
give you a good result
but don't come
micromanaging me leave it to me i know
best so that's my working app that's my
basic working attitude
um
and so we gel quite well it's a great
idea
i i do it and you didn't mess with me
give him a good book and then he sells
it and then a book arrives like that's a
great way to work that's a boss
most people's bosses
they're not like that those are the
bosses
there's that bill hicks sketch
about the boss you remember listen to
bill hicks yeah but not this one
he just he's just talking why he likes
being a stand-up comedian
and he goes the only thing really he
likes about being a stand-up comedian
because he just whinges about the the
long days on the road and the failed
relationships and all that stuff and you
guys but the thing about being a
standard community is you don't have a
boss
and the same is true about being
a popular
or a you know
trade historian
with a good publisher
not a boss you want a boss i don't want
a boss
no you don't
you don't
you don't have to worry about it all
right so the begin
the beginning yeah yeah yeah the
beginning let's get to the beginning
right why does why is rome [ __ ]
why why why is that wrecked
well gibbon took six volumes to get get
to the bottom of this didn't he but
let's let's try it quickly um
there are lots of reasons why the roman
empire in the west fell in the 5th
century
in powers and thrones i started the very
beginning and
start with a cyclical shift in the
climate of the mediterranean world
after the roman climate optimum
a period of relatively warm relatively
wet weather highly conducive to
agriculture
highly conducive to an empire feeding
itself
after that entered a cyclical downturn
of slightly cooler slightly drier
regional
climate
um
and
rome came under so that's the sort of
threat that's the climate framing and
then rome comes under enormous pressure
from waves of migrants
waves set in chain by a short sharp mega
drought
in the far east which moved tribes
called the huns huns bumped into the
goths and the allens
uh alan the goths and the allens
particularly the goths found their way
towards the borders of the roman
empire in both east
and eventually west
um
put enormous pressure on a political
system that was already
uh
faltering because of
problems some of which were related to
simple size the roman empire was it was
too massive to be
uh it was like a very unstable very
large star you know they they they start
to become unstable under the the
pressure of their own mass and gravity
and so that that that would have been a
long-term process within the roman
empire empire
so this is a combination of factors
which by the beginning of the fifth
century lead to
uh a sort of breaking up process of the
western roman empire and then in 410 the
symbolic sacking of rome
um not just symbolic i mean damaging and
and uh
and shocking
but most of all symbolic sacrifice and
the goss and that didn't herald the
immediate end of the roman empire or
even the immediate end of the roman
empire in the west
but it it was a sort of i mean the crass
modern analogy is with 9 11. it was a
sort of
even at the time it seemed like a sea
change kind of moment which seemed to
herald a new phase in history and in
retrospect
uh has bee has retained that
that reputation
all right so rome's [ __ ] why was it
that for the
rest of time
no one appears to have been able to
replicate
a empire of their sort of size i guess
the british tried to do it but we're
outside of the middle ages then was
there something just inherently unstable
about our area of the world
oh so you mean an empire in
europe or an empire in the world an
empire in
europe napoleon would have something to
say
was that equivalent sizing to
the romans
napoleon and charlotte okay so look the
romans are the only imperial power to
have
ruled the entire coastal literal of the
mediterranean so we'll give them that
um
uh which is hard to do
it's just hard to do i mean that's like
napoleon would probably have like why is
it hard to do
because it's a vast
uh
area in the just in the first instance
although yes of course the british have
commanded the great empire the mongols
commanded an enormous land empire
in the in the middle ages and uh the
arabs uh you know the first islamic
caliphate probably came the closest to
emulating rome
um but the roman imperial system was uh
was was uniquely
um effective for its time
and you had as a perfect combination of
overwhelming
um
by an order of magnitude military
capability
a sort of analogous to the modern united
states was sort of much much greater
than the modern united states in
comparison to every other power
certainly in their region
you had in the sort of peak of the
imperial
um
age a
a highly
effective
um
sort of and
replicable
political system with a with what i
think was very important about it was
um
a
a pan-roman culture a culture that went
beyond sort of regional culture
um so that romans living in villas in
britannia would feel something in common
with romans living in a villa
in
uh north africa
or sicily or rome so you know so you
have a common language you have of
course they're famous roads
um
you have the concept of citizenship
although by of course not unique to the
roman empire but which uh which binds a
sort of ruling class together uh by
self-interest as much as anything else
you have a sophisticated um
uh body of law you know you did all of
these ingredients of the roman empire
come together over there built up over a
long time
uh and it's it's hard to attribute
their success to one
of those things on its own
but
in the time since
rome's fall
it's proven
difficult it's proven impossible uh for
any
number of generations for for another
power to put together that sort of
unique combination of building blocks of
empire i mean that
people try in the middle ages who came
closest well
i think the
yeah as i said already the um
you know the umayyad caliphate
up until the middle of the eighth
century
um
i think you know charlemagne gave it a
good go
ah
although you know that the problem with
um
[Music]
with charlemagne's empire was that it
was like napoleon's which i've also
mentioned highly dependent on one
charismatic and uh and visionary
individual at the the head of it should
have been should have got your publisher
yeah like he'd be a great um
he'd be he's an empire builder
he should have got him in
well he wasn't around
should have fixed it should have worked
it out somehow okay
i lost bill and ted
should have got some sort of a solution
got him in could have published some
great books and held onto an empire for
a bit longer
it would have been a tyrannical empire
but then that is the most effective
but you said you just let everyone get
on with their own thing it would have
been fine
uh he lets me get i didn't say let's
everyone get on with her anything
he's able to give sovereignty to those
who deserve it
right okay that's a good leadership
principle yeah i like it
jocko willing
exactly yeah extreme ownership but only
for the people that deserve it
only for the people that deserve it not
for you doesn't come with a lot of
caveats does he
no fairly simple him and goggins fairly
simple right down the back of a post-it
note witch goggins walton goggins david
goggins i don't know about that because
i only know about walton goggins david
goggins is like
a hardcore
black
thinner jocko
out of the marines
so he's a marine
and then he's done ultra races and he
goes on rogan and he swears a lot and he
says stay hard
and
that's good advice and that's what he
does yesterday
well he seems to say to every situation
actually it's like it's like a one size
fixes all solution to just stay hard
um which jocko doesn't talk about
actually so maybe that's maybe if you
were to blend the two together you'd
have someone have a great tan
uh they'd have good endurance there'd be
a brazilian
uh
jiu-jitsu black belt they all do
do you do jiu-jitsu no i don't and i
don't think that david goggins does but
he does tie his hands behind his back
and his feet together and get dropped
into water quite a lot because he's got
he's got a fear of water
so he overcomes his fear of water by
being hog-tied and thrown in
um there's a there's a sort of
historical tradition going on i know
it's like new because the
the broadcasting medium is new but that
kind of goes like that definitely goes
back to houdini doesn't it
like super physically hard i'm gonna do
some ridiculous stunts that's gonna you
know scare the [ __ ] out of you if you
empathize for one second
you know if david blaine had come along
like
15 20 years later that dude would have
he'd have been a joker or whatever i
think you reckon
yeah i think so i think he's a bit
mindful for that i think he's a bit
sort of
complex
not that jocko and goggins are simple
humans
yeah just in case they're listening
because it'll [ __ ] me up um but
i do think that they're
from what i know of david blaine he
seems like a pretty
fairly sort of complex character
i'm not sure that you can come up with
stay hard
if you are
if you're as complex as david blaine i
think yeah i know you're right you know
what blaine should have been he if
blaine came along now i know he'd be
what
he'd be a peloton instructor he would be
a peloton instructor like the
soulfulness plus the physical you love
your peloton don't you
do i ever set a personal best this
morning came second was it was it today
second
yeah but you know like do you ride pedal
tom no
okay let me tell you this you get on a
live ride
let's say it's a 30 minute
hitting hills ride just say doesn't have
to be but let's say it is
you're going to know within
the first three minutes
like
if there's there's going to be a couple
of people like if they're there they're
there you just know you're not going to
keep up with those people
they're like they must i think they're
probably professional riders or they're
certainly like those skinny 50 year old
dudes you see out for doing 100 miles
every sunday
riding from london to brighton and stuff
um
but i'm not that dude
uh what do you know
i'm an
elite dabbler
like the king of the dabblers
so i'm not a pro
i'm not going to be a pro
but uh
i'm i'm usually i'm there what they're
about i'm top ten
top ten who usually better
number two today who do you get by today
some bastard i'm not just some dude i
don't even know i kind of like his name
was i don't know
andy spin 36 or something i don't know
dan jones that's who we need right
that's who we need to but i was racist i
was racing there was a woman i was
racing for number three position that
was a good race and i heard a personal
quest i'm very i'm very pro peloton and
i'll tell you why not not just for the
um
the physical fitness aspect although
that is superb and they've got great
trainers and like you get you're gonna
do well if you if you join peloton
but i like the cod philosophy i buy into
that west coast kind of
um
selfish hippie thing i don't
i don't believe it per se like i am
aware that this is like a lot of
gobbledygook
but i also
buy into it in the moment and i think
that like
i think that's how cuts work
i don't think that all of manson's
family
well i
well yeah i'm very pro this like
not i don't think they're unquestioning
like that's like you know
the dudes with koresh
i don't think they were all like
completely brainwashed i don't think
cults are all completely brainwashing
it's full of people who are like why do
i believe this [ __ ] i don't know but i
do
there's nothing to do with the middle
ages but peloton's occult i spoke to
danny trejo you know the guy from connor
tell me more well let me tell you about
danny trejo uh he was
hypnotized by charles manson
in county jail
of course he was so charles manson was
in there and he was a little guy little
charlie he called him yeah and charlie
was getting picked on by the bigger guys
but someone had told danny
that
that charlie could hypnotize you to get
you loaded up on heroin so he could
hypnotize you so that it was like that
you were high on heroin again so they
started looking after him because he was
able to
psychologically deploy drugs to them and
apparently it was just like being on
heroin so he got hypnotized into
believing that he was loaded
in the in the prison and looked after
charles manson for a while
it's a pretty good story pretty [ __ ]
good another story about danny trejo he
won he once saved kefa sutherland from a
stalker so keith sutherland guy from 24
had this bodyguard dude apparently
people in hollywood like being around
tough men
that are just part of their posse or
whatever
and this this guy had started
misbehaving and then had started
threatening kiefer
so danny said danny told kiefer that he
was gonna sort it um which
in keith's defense i would have thought
meant get him killed as well whack him
uh didn't mean that just meant like i'll
it'll be
but it's danny trejo like he's a pretty
intimidating fella with a big tattoo so
uh but he went away and he he sent this
dude after danny and his friend paid him
a visit uh he sent kiefer's wife and
kiefer a bouquet of flowers and a
handwritten note apologizing and saying
that he hopes they have a good life
so
useful friend to have if you're ever
over in uh
hollywood
useful you've got to know danny trey
yeah and he'll [ __ ] people up he's
really hard so i sat opposite mickey
rourke in like an in the air new zealand
lounge in lax years ago
and
yeah you'd have thought rock would be
intimidating raw i didn't find mickey
rook intimidating
i'd be intimidated if i sat up is it
danny treyard but he's proper [ __ ]
people uh he's hard i'm not sure how
much mickey rock mickey rock just looks
like he's been [ __ ] up
he does now yeah
yeah
seriously i think being hard like as
like to try and make this about history
yeah well we have to you know enjoying
it yeah
i think being hard
is definitely
historically
that's a historical moving factor that
we don't think about a lot what do you
mean
i mean
you know when you know someone is hard
they're dif they're just like they're
different like jocko's hard right
jocko is a hard man
and i don't need to know all the [ __ ] he
did in like navy seal three or team
three or whatever he was in
to know
that i'm just i'm not gonna [ __ ] with
him
i don't give out that sort of vibe i
even no matter how like how many how
like much i squatted or like pressed or
whatever how big or god or like i'm
never going to be hard no one's ever
going to be like oh no that i've changed
it's hard that's not right okay
some people are just but i think they're
just hot they're just hard it's just
their vibe it's a thing they give you
they're just hard
and
i suspect that if you met attila the hun
right you reckon he's hard in the mid
5th century
i reckon the guy's heart i think genghis
khan is like just a just like a hard
people who do you reckon the hardest man
from the middle ages or woman
i want to get it right if i make him
because he's hard
i think
i was thinking so
you know i've been talking about this
book a lot someone said okay well come
on then why did genghis khan put
together the greatest land contiguous
land empire seen in the middle ages and
like the answer isn't just because he
was hard
but that i went through like a whole
like
well
the structure of mongol tribal society
in the late 12th century was such and
such and there are some climate factors
probably at play and
uh you know the relative
organization of
genghis khan's meritocratic uh
reorganized mongol army
versus the uh the you know the decadent
imperial societies
i didn't mention the guy who must have
just been like double heart
but i think i think that's gonna have
been a factor
don't you
we know how people one of the things
i've tried to get to in like okay this
is all silly
but there is a sort of serious point and
when i was writing i'm writing this big
book a thousand years of medieval
history and i've tried in this more than
i've tried in other books tried really
hard to have this kind of stuff in mind
um
really try and think clearly about
about things and try and um
bring it into
without i don't know don't dumb down i
you know i'd sound dumb when i'm talking
to you obviously but
in the books they're not they're not
dumbed down
books this isn't simple wikipedia
but it does have a they do have a
sensibility of
well what's this like
in modern terms
um
i was i think
i think it was when i was writing about
the
uh yeah the early
the rise of the arabs you know the first
generation muhammad's companions
the first conquest out of arabia
and um the you know the arabs of
muhammad's time are described as um
like the sons of ishmael you know the
wild ass of a man his hand against
everyone's and everyone's against his
like that's poetic and that's that's you
know that's biblical uh it's
um sounds good
but it
it also as i was writing i remember
writing that chapter i think if that
reminds me much more of something you
know what how would i explain that to
somebody who didn't really dig on
uh the poetry of biblical illusion
didn't really get down with a wild ass
of a man as as being a great i was like
this is like millwall fc right this is
like millwall no one likes us we don't
care
now you're talking because that's the
same human instinct that's the same
human kind of like
basic uh we're mean attitude
um and although the fortunes and the
rise of millwall fc's terrorist
supporters in the late 20th and early
21st century have nothing whatsoever to
do
uh beyond that
with the rise of the arabs in the early
islamic caliphates
i still think it's like elementally
something human that that joins those
two
um phenomena that one should actually
point out without fear of of
you know being a badass story so what
you're saying
is
that the echoes of the millwall terrace
reverberate through time
no that's not what i'm saying oh i'm
saying
that what you hear
echoing on the middle wall terrace
is a uh a human trait as old as time
cantankerous aggressive
me
yes there we are now we've come back now
we've not hard not hard enough to pull
it off right what about what about this
sort of stereotype poster boy then for
the middle ages that's got to be knights
is it knights that kind of everyone
thinks middle ages and they think
knights
uh well it's two things isn't it i mean
if i'm if i said to you uh christy fancy
coming to my medieval fantasy dress
party yeah assuming you weren't just
totally weirded out hang on hang on hang
on hang on middle ages
medieval
what's what's going on there it's the
same word but different
yeah oh one answer latinate ones oh so
they're just interchangeable
yeah ah cool sweet except medieval is an
adjective in the middle ages isn't it
okay
don't worry
you can use either there's no judgment i
will
on my history peloton
um
[Music]
night so if i'm inviting you to my
medieval fantasy dress party my
hypothetical medieval don't worry i'm
not having one and they're not going to
invite you after this show okay
it's a hypothetical part of it
i said yeah you got you gotta come into
costume you i think you're coming as one
of two things you're one of three things
like you might come as uh like a saucy
wench you might do that yep oh you're
very i could see i know i could see me
doing that
you could be like
i got good legs put that aside okay if
the winch option is off the tape i say
that no wenches okay
uh if the wench option is off the table
i think you're gonna come as either uh
a night
or you know a version of the night or
you're going to come as
a monk
yeah i was going to say wizard but
monk's like the real version of a wizard
don't come as a wizard you won't be
allowed
is there no wizards no wizards or
wenches
winches yes there's no wizards
[ __ ] sake
you're gonna come as a monkey a night
just say yes i am yes
yeah thank you i thought you were now
you're going to come to the monkey night
because those are the two great
archetypes
of the middle ages you know the the
churchmen
of course a lot of different churchmen
doesn't have to be but let's say the
monk the churchman over here and the
fighting man over here
and
those are fascinating roles because to a
large extent
they are
productive and unique
to for the products of the middle ages
so
before the middle ages you have ascetics
for sure christian ascetics desert style
ideas you know all of that some stuff
but they're not monks as we think of
them
um
and you in a similar way before them
before the middle east actually before
about the 10th century you have
warriors who fight
on horseback
who ride into battle and or fight on
horseback
but you don't have knights in the
frankish tradition who fight with a
couch lance mechanical savile and saddle
and stirrups and
uh and who have this sort of code
of
chivalry which which is like bonded
around everything that they do and
infused within
their their mindset and so so i think
those two
i give i gave a chapter to each of those
in in powers and thrones because i think
that not only are these
very very symbolic of
uh and particular to the middle ages
these these groups of monks and nines
um
i think that they're
also like through examining those
archetypes you can tell some really
interesting stories about power now this
book is called powers and thrones
because one of its uh its
driving underpinning concerns is what is
power in the middle ages what does it
look like is it just political power is
it just
uh military power is it just being hard
um and
what's what plasma throughout this does
is sort of meditate across the the
course of the book on on the different
forms power can take in human society as
exemplified in the middle ages
where's the power coming from
fundamentally
well power doesn't empower
that kind it's like saying where does
energy come from i mean power doesn't
come from anywhere but power power is uh
is
manifested
um in different ways and and and power
can take different forms
and so in the middle ages you know
in my career to date in the books i'd
written i've written
what i've done
a lot i've done some dynastic history so
that's power as
family power as um kingship power as
political system
pretty much
i've done templars and crusaders okay so
that's that's power through
religion and and that's power through
military force
but i was aware
having having written those books that
there were there were large
areas of medieval history that i i
hadn't really written about directly
and that were important if you were
trying to think about how what power is
and how it's manifest so
besides the the constitutional the
political the military the religious
there's also the um
the operation of the
institution so monks is a good example
of this if you think about cluniak
monasticism
it's
institutional power it's it's
non-military
it's not overtly political it's it's
sort of it is religious but it's more
than that it's cultural it's
as i say it's institutional though the
growth of cognac monasticism from
out of burgundy along these um
pilgrim roads joining
much of western europe
enriching you know a system which self
enriches a system which which ha
spreads its influence across borders
irrespective of political rulers a
system which
grants its institutional leaders
equivalent power to political leaders
without a state beneath them uh
equivalent wealth to political leaders
without a state to provide it like that
that's a really interesting story it has
echoes
or superficial as they may be but echoes
of
things we're dealing with now
in terms of you know big companies like
facebook apple google
um
amazon
how these stateless institutions
uh
are bending the world
and and and they're they're factors that
political leaders of states have to
consider so um
so i think that that that story of monks
for example just as an example is one
that uh that takes you
not just into the sort of cloister and
and the everyday humdrum reality of
medieval monasticism but actually to
thinking quite deeply about what power
is and how it can be
deployed
talking about the modern day and mill
wall and stuff that happens now
just coming out the back end of a
pandemic hopefully uh a lot of pandemics
in the middle ages a lot of those
running around
in the middle ages yeah i mean is the
the big one's a black death in the 14th
century
nearly the end though they just picked
the post you know they only had 100
years before rome got wrecked again and
then they'd have been missed off they'd
been in whatever comes after
well there's an argument that says no
black death uh
a a much delayed renaissance and
you know the the the counter factual
with no black death is very very very
hard to play
um
so i it's not as
it can't be
we can't be too certain
that uh had the black death not come
along you would still have seen the sack
of rome in 1527
but in answer to your first question
the the big pandemics of the middle ages
yeah you've got like black death of the
mid-14th century and then the waves all
the way through to 1390s
and
much earlier than that in fact
800
years earlier than that you have the
justinianic plague playing justinian
harder really to be certain about it's
it's spread it's virulence uh much more
much more reliant on impressionistic
evidence
play well
the accounts of chroniclers saying oh my
god it was terrible there was like mad
lockdowns and thousands of people
dying all the time
um
you know there's there is
far less
like i'm getting super nerdy so
the justinian justinianic plague of the
sixth century a.d
seems to have been similar to the black
death in that it was a form of
bubonic plague
which
mutated very very very infectious and
very very very deadly
the trouble is
we know a lot about the black death and
very little about the justinianic plague
a lot of what we have to surmise about
the justinianic plague
is surmised by taking what we know of
the black death and then transposing its
uh
say its rate of spread and its lethality
back onto the fragments of evidence we
have from the sixth century
so that the range of estimates of how
many people
so with the black death of the 14th
century we know with a reasonable degree
of certainty that it's uh
50 60 percent of the population of
western europe are killed by the black
death
we can we can be quite certain about
that although it varies from place to
place we'd be quite certain about that
however because of the fragmentary
nature of the evidence about the sixth
century
justinianic plague
you're sort of using models from the
14th century and putting them on top of
very very s uh scant evidence and and so
the high range of estimates for deaths
in the just in that plague i think runs
to like 100 million but the low range
runs to about 50 000.
good confidence interval
well it's a problem right
now if you just read the chroniclers
of the from the sixth century
that tallies with this idea that it's
closer to a hundred million into fifty
thousand
but the trouble is that chroniclers we
don't tend to trust chroniclers and they
tend to
get a bit hot under the collar i mean if
you only had daily mail and or sun or
guardian editorials to go by as your as
your historical source you would have
somewhat warped idea about the history
of
the current pandemic
right you want some stats you want some
data man
give me some data give me some hard data
chronic chroniclers is that not what
chroniclers are supposed to do it's kind
of in the name chronicling things not
pundits punditras that wasn't their name
yes but there's so um
but if you take a we we would call say
procopius of caesarea a chronicler
um
he'd fallen under that broad term
because he writes histories
and contemporary histories of what he's
living through in the age of justinian
but the guy is
much closer to
a
paid by the inch
um
[Music]
like
shock columnist gossip gossip
no not gossip
i mean a sort of a
like a
rented opinion
it's not quite katie hopkins well as as
was before she got back or he's like
peter's morgan right all right yeah
what's the issue of the day morgan's got
two takes and he just like goes okay
that one
uh
and he's he's absolutely brilliant i
mean totally amoral as a journalist i
don't know personally maybe a nice guy
and
may not be i don't know but um
as a journalist he's brilliant
because he's either
like completely enraging
or completely sympathetic depending on
where you stand on on this particular
issue
and procopius caesar is sort of similar
very very similar to piers morgan
so if you take it here's a good example
of this
it could be caesar is is you know
supposedly chronicle or well he's just
writing what happened
like morgan would say i'm just a
journalist you know
um
spends half his career
toadying up unbelievably
to justinian the emperor unbelievably
yeah the sort of flatterer the kind of
writing
the histories of the wars of justinian
and kind of blowing endless smoke up the
empress
and then he writes the secret history
which is like uh
the most
offensive
damning um
tell all expose character assassination
mudslinging
like horror show
of an account of justinian and theodore
uh which
smears them absolutely smears them i
mean it's so entertaining it's great
but it's like a hell of a flip-flop
um
and people sort of scratch their heads
oh this is you know what what's going on
with procopius of caesarea man just look
at piers morgan and megan okay the dude
couldn't get his nose out of her
uh
and then she kind of snubbed him and so
he becomes her worst enemy it's an old
story it's an old story
um
but it's
you know so anyway the point was is you
know chroniclers don't know they don't
just chronicle of course
their opinion
was that's that's the foreign fashion
you've shown your age there yeah you're
stin
you grew up in the age of spin spinny
hendrix it's because i love the thick of
it that's why uh what about technology
there's like the dark ages are
completely encompassed by this
middle ages period
what about technology because it feels i
don't know this is me talking as the guy
that doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about most of the time but
specifically when it comes to
the history of the planet that i live on
and
i don't see
it feels like rome had a lot sorted
and then you come out the other side at
the renaissance
and we've got
what have we got to show for it like
some art
some castles which you have profited
from massively
and
no i
don't presume
and
some death some plagues like
is no one adventuring or technologying
during this period what's happening
well there's no doubt that the roman
empire had um achieved a sort of
technological spike in the graph if you
like
um
[Music]
very inventive and ingenious uh
age
underpinned of course by
mass slavery
and one of the reasons that
certain societies have been able to
build
fast and high and impressive and large
is because they've enslaved
uh tens of that you know ancient
egyptians aliens aliens like the
egyptians enslaved yes yes yes of course
i've forgotten about that um
so
but you know there's no no so after the
breakup of the roman empire in the west
there's no doubt that you see
all sorts of networks broken
uh over what used to be the western
roman empire
some of those are knowledge networks and
some of those are technological exchange
networks and some of those
just our wealth networks
so it takes a long time
for
certainly western europe
and i'm i'm being quite specific about
western europe to recover
uh to a point of of
similar technological sophistication but
it doesn't take as long as you're
suggesting when do you think that is
when do they get back to you
whether it's it's about getting back to
par but getting back to a um
a society that is
uh becoming
that is every generation seems to
becoming wealthier and more creative and
more inventive and more um thirsty for
knowledge and more capable of deploying
that knowledge to useful ends
it's around the millennium that you you
start to see
technology new technology starting to
transform the way that people live let's
let's take
one small example we talked earlier we
didn't really talk earlier we mentioned
earlier nights
if you take
the stirrup um
and the arrival the importation of
stirrup technology from
east to west
when 8th century maybe 9th century
sometime like this it takes a while to
arrive and to spread
but certainly by the millennium the
stirrup
people are riding the stirrups i do
in the 12th century it's just part of
iran in fact you couldn't have nights
without stirrups because you couldn't if
you think about um
[Music]
trying to joust on horseback you should
give an alliance you're going to need a
couple of things on the horse you're
going to need a saddle
right
and you're going to need stirrups
because otherwise if you ride that horse
at something and try and jabber at that
lance what's going to happen is the
horse will go that way and you will go
that way and it will be comical until
you break your pelvis on your full
it will still be comical but not for you
uh
so
the the invention of the stirrup enables
us
a military revolution because it enables
the development of frankish cavalry and
frankish cavalry to take one example are
a
central part of the success of the first
crusade now the first crusade
we could argue as a transformative
political
uh event in the history of the whole
middle ages but
although this sounds a bit butterfly
effect the first crusade might not have
been possible without the invention of
the stirrup which seems to us an
impossibly simple piece of technology
but it is very important
and from that point you know from around
the 10th 11th century you start to see
in western europe
um
inventions you know windmills windmills
sound kind of boring but they they
they're incredibly important for the
development of aquaculture
um i see a rising population which is
able to feed itself better because you
have um
uh you know you have improvements in
plow technology these are unglamorous
things but you know agricultural
technology improves military technology
improves
um so it's earlier than you think that
the difference starts to be made the
asteroid comes back into society or
comes into you know western society from
uh from the greeks and the arabs
and that makes navigation a lot easier
what about warfare any warfare
technology developments
well by the 14th century you studied
gunpowder
i mean that's i mean gunpowder is a sort
of end of the middle late middle ages
end of the middle ages kind of
phenomenon and we tend to associate the
arrival of gunpowder on the battlefields
with
the end of the middle ages but um it's
it's there quite early on in the again
in the west
uh
in
in in the late middle ages so um
and then in armor technology yeah look
you see
armor and arms i mean
think about
it's a good example
frankish swords frank's extremely famous
for uh for producing high quality swords
um well what was so high quality about
them what'd they do
well no it doesn't shatter on impact
mainly
um
capable of maintaining a sharp a sharper
edge
uh
if you think about the development of
armor between i mean think about the
norm and close your eyes think about the
tapestry as i uh i say to all my lovers
um
and what are they wearing like
male link on it's
the political terms chainmail that's
tautology but you know male armor
uh the development of that to by the
14th century largely plate armor enables
um
heavier fighting
closer at hand on foot and
bigger armies required longbow
technology
lots of developments that seem seem
quite primitive to us because we we're
in a nuclear age and we're post
the barbed wire machine guns the
trenches but
technological and then you mentioned
navigation well
again by the early 15th century you've
got boat technology and navigation
technology improving to the point that
two generations before columbus sailed
for the uh for the indies and bumped
into the americas
um and henry the navigator
the portuguese sending
trips ever further down the west african
coast
uh and coming back it wasn't the problem
wasn't going down because it was coming
back uh so
uh but long before that even if you look
around the turn of the millennium to go
back to sort of where i started
uh you've got europeans in the americas
but vikings over at lanza meadows
around the year 1 000.
so medivh technology is
is more sophisticated than perhaps we
give it credit
yeah it's a weird one because the way
that technology works it
enables further developments to be made
so you do have this sort of exponential
curve that comes in as something
gets enabled then that enables something
else that goes down there and it kind of
feels like where you're leaving the
story whatever 1500 in a bit
that
there's a lot of
the
fundamental pieces in place
to allow pirates within 300 years to
allow bigger buildings to allow faster
development
faster travel so on and so forth more
dangerous weapons
um well okay but let's take those in
terms pirates
they've always been pirates
um but they've been able to travel as
far across the ocean where they've been
able to do
depends how far you don't need to travel
very far to be a part i mean if you look
at uh
caribbean obviously that's where jack
sparrow is yeah like you've just watched
too many movies that's that's the
problem yeah yeah because
the pirates the pirates of the
mediterranean there's a story that you
you could set in any bloody age
really
pirates of the mediterranean that's what
this thing is yeah it sounds like you
know fighting
the mediterranean fighting over pasta
that's what they could have had
okay keep it up
uh
what was the next thing you said i was
about to demolish
uh buildings big big buildings yes
buildings
lincoln cathedral lincoln cathedral
halfway between you
biggest building in the world mate for a
while it was bigger than the period yeah
until the spire blew down but that was
bigger than the great pyramid
giza it's on a big hill isn't it
and it was the uh yeah but we're not
counting the hill
it's even better because on the top of
the hill
but the [ __ ] eiffel tower on top of a
hill
and count the hill
oh man
the dome of the rock's big isn't it what
oh it's on a hill
it makes it look bigger well everyone's
done that everyone's everyone's pulled
something down around something that
they're trying to make look bigger to
create the illusion that the thing that
they're trying to make look bigger
actually is bigger you're talking about
manscaping
manscaping
i wasn't actually aware was a specific
term although man's skateboard support
manto manscaping
no
like shaving your cubes yeah but i mean
i didn't know that it was like a pursuit
that people went into is there like a
subreddit for it
i don't know there's like a peloton
class for you just click the button
that's next to yoga manscape
yeah man skate going back to the peloton
thing because i that we left you left a
little bit
no but you left a
don't take my account away un
closed loop about peloton
because you
have a family with what sounds like a
small child
did you specifically not get the
treadmill because it's good at
propelling
infants into
this do you see mostly firstly the tread
plus has only just been released in the
uk
uh yeah i'm aware of the uh the problems
with treadmills are dangerous i mean no
it's not just and i'm not like a peloton
either ambassador i wish i were or
evangelist
that kind of am but treadmills are
dangerous treadmills have been dangerous
they've always been dangerous poor old
mike tyson's daughter died in treadmill
didn't she didn't know that that's very
very very
people with kids don't let your [ __ ]
kids near your treadmill
do not do it they're really dangerous no
i don't got the treadmill also i'm not
really a runner
um uh no yes i wouldn't i wouldn't have
and also i've i've had it since
um
i built a gym in lockdown and went in
earlier in the year
but no i didn't choose a bike ride on
the train for that reason i chose a bike
because at the time it was the only
piece of equipment available but it's
the piece of equipment i would have
chosen anyway uh-huh uh-huh how
fortunate well the tread plus if they'd
had that
in the middle i wouldn't have chosen
that i was not a runner i'm just not a
runner
and small child that can be
fired underneath you
you tread more i just think i just think
if you've got a kid if you just just
cycle for a bit
for the
the years that your child can't avoid a
treadmill that seems on the road run
outside i don't know
like to each their own man uh it's hard
enough to get people to get off their
asses
right but like i just think
like it's like if you've got a cooker
well you're gonna let the kid crawl in
the [ __ ] oven
no of course you're not cause you know
that thing is dangerous
don't juggle the knives no i know
they're dangerous
a treadmill is dangerous it's a
dangerous piece of equipment yeah don't
let your kids play on it and now it
pisses me
i'm sorry i'm sorry i apologize look
i'll let you how about something nice
how about something nice
someone
from your research for the book
that you think more people should know
about
dick whittington dick whittington for
star all i know all i know about dick
whittington is i've seen many
harsh monogram images of him
wearing high boots and a big floppy hat
that is the beginning and the end of my
understanding about diquitting did he do
something with a cat
did he ever
in real life no and so the pantomime
character didn't put into the knapsack
on his back cat inside goes to london
core blimey governor i'm not doing too
well here i'm off
uh
starts to leave bow bells no no come
back mate oh the cat's gone on a ship
some some [ __ ] happened
all is well like that's the plot of the
pantomime
but in reality dick whittington was
like a super dawn oligarch with a
conscience i mean the guy's legendary
mayor of london four times mayor of
calais once
um
rolled through fought in the reigns of
five plantagenet kings edward iii
richard the second henry the fourth
fifth sixth um survived the revolution
of 1399
uh sold not only sold sort of high-end
cloth to uh the kings but traded in wind
you know commodity trader uh raised
finance to keep the government afloat
during the agincourt campaign traded you
know it was effectively a high-end bail
bondsman after agincourt trading
prince prisoners ransoms and when he
died in 1423 he left so much money to
the city of london uh for good works
there's you know new libraries
uh sewers public toilets single mothers
refuges uh arms houses social housing he
left so much money there's still people
living in dick whittington houses today
in 1423
guys it's an extraordinary story now
i'm not going to the pantomime with my
kids and as soon as whittington walks on
stage go box
well like that mate
four times
oh are you gonna get to the bit about
the public toilets no thought not no i'm
not that guy
i let it ride but he's in the book
i want to know more about him
you know what to do that's it
you got you got one of those
oh yeah i got a limited edition proof
with uh and i don't know if the hardback
has this it's got sort of a foil
recess
oh yeah
that's nice that is nice
i uh limited edition proof
200 i think
oh yeah
this is big this is big dick [ __ ]
dick whittington one one issue that you
get when you get pre-release proofs is
uh because
mistakes the page no i like the mistakes
i think they're very charming um because
the pages are likely to change
um
none of the maps that you promised me in
terms of the page numbers are easy to
find so they've all just got x's where
the page marks are supposed to be so
when i wanted to skip through and just
spend
10 minutes looking at some maps
i had to
do this
your concern is noted and will be
ignored okay well that's a shame but
don jones ladies and gentlemen
powers and thrones will be linked in the
show notes below you can go and get it
from amazon
uh what are you doing next also actually
before we go i gotta bring this up man
how [ __ ] cool is it
as a historian and how fortunate are we
as an audience
right now for the kind of
environment or ecology that history's
got going on so like timeline world
history documentaries on youtube i
tweeted this earlier on today
that should be 20 pounds a month
like that youtube channel should be 20
pounds a month history here all of the
stuff that you do like there's just it's
from your side of the aisle
you know
as a creator and as a historian is it
like [ __ ] this is like a big resurgence
of of history content and interest and
it's cool and accessible
and like
not safe
quite
20 years ago
when i was studying i was an
undergraduate twenty
two years ago
um
i was taught to write by david starkey
and so at that point starkey was at the
absolute pinnacle of his uh his fame
and um
he was doing using six million viewers
on channel four so it shows about
elizabeth six
million
six million that's a trumpism that i i
need to shake
um
that's incredible and shama was on the
telly doing history of britain like
banging out millions of viewers
like there was there was mad money going
into commissioning from
certainly channel 4 bbc
uh and those people were saying oh you
know history's kind of cool again
so
but it hasn't really tailed off from
there like
the budgets in broadcasting like from
the networks are through the floor now
and even the castle show
the fire commissioned well the budget
for that was i i would
uh i can't remember but let's say it was
in the ballpark maybe slightly under 200
grand an hour which was good decent then
but not exceptional
well now budgets are like
and last time i checked in about 80
grand an hour for the similar ambition
of programming and your time
in both the field and the edit is like
nothing
so
there has certainly been a drop off in
the ambition of network tv commissioning
and at the same time
you've seen streamers come in who will
commission history and then netflix and
emotion networks but if you're going to
commission history on history docs type
stuff on netflix it's got to have like
clooney doing the voice over or um nick
cage in it or some [ __ ] like that so uh
so
there you know that there's not the
middle of the market on the tv has
fallen out but as you correctly identify
people like the man dan snow doing mad
stuff with history here it's fantastic
and they're they've you know there are
so many broadcasters and outlets and so
many people
podcasting and you know bbc history
extra of stepped into you know with a
sort of nimble uh approach to
commissioning that
[Music]
the bbc the institution
notably lacks
um so there is loads of
there are loads of channels to market
there's enormous public enthusiasm for
history there are lots of people doing
it most of whom
are extremely nice and collegiate and
friendly to one another we don't really
have the kind of uh [ __ ] hatreds and
rivalries of that shana starkey era
so it's like it's good times it's really
really good times and um
uh i'm like blessed to be doing it
what are you doing next we got your
fiction book out as well as this history
fiction
yeah [ __ ] that
i'm out i'm going to make it up
um
i don't know
no i do know
i don't know about in terms of history
anymore uh but i do know that i've got
so next week
assuming this maybe it's this week
maybe on the 7th of october yeah
i've got a little ghost story coming out
which i wrote on halloween for halloween
last year
um
and that's an original medieval ghost
story written about the year 1400 it's
called the tale of well i've called it
the taylor taylor the tale of the taylor
and the three dead kings
it's a little tiny book
um a rewritten retold original medieval
ghost story
that's that's super fun and then i'm
doing a
historical fiction trilogy so next
autumn the first one comes out it's
called essex dogs and it's about
it's the the all three books are set in
100 years war and essex dogs are set in
30 46 the cresley campaign
the second one
is siege of calais the third one is
something else
but they take the sensibility of the
sort of apocalypse now platoon
full metal jacket
and band of brothers saying private ryan
to an extent but more the kind of like
hardcore war as hell
late 20th century
uh dystopian
american hard-boiled approach
to the war novel and set in the middle
ages so there's no [ __ ] hey nonnie no
my liege andy greenwood tree and
everyone's chivalrous and uh thinking
only a fair fair lady
this is like
each chapter starts with a line from
like fossa or one of those sort of
highfaluting chivalry is great
chroniclers and then each chapter
rips the idea of chivalry to bits on the
ground because the reality of war for a
platoon moving you're landing on the
normandy beaches in
july 46 and then having to fight their
way to the rivers up the rivers and the
cross and then you know after seven
weeks in the field fight the battle
that's horrible
and that's undocumented well it's
largely undocumented and but if you
write against the grain of
the chronicles it creates
you and you couldn't do it in history i
i don't think it would be possible to do
in history
but it's super possible to do it in
fiction
and
uh um so that's the next project
uh i have a
deal with sony pictures to develop
historical drama
so i'm doing that at the moment um
we had one on earlier this year and
there's more coming down the line i hope
um
i'm doing a [ __ ] ton of pellets on man
riding every day most important thing
extreme dabbler
love it
don jones ladies and gentlemen powers
and thrones will be linked in the show
notes below you should go and get it and
uh watch out for dan jones on your
peloton chasing you down
thanks brother
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace